bonjour si je vous parle de la mère des
droits des femmes vous me suis très
peut-être Olympe de Gouges Emmeline
Pankhurst mais il est grand temps de se
décentrer de notre vision européenne du
féminisme et d'aborder une femme hyper
badass que j'ai découverte récemment de
médailles aux en somme Kuti aussi
surnommée la lionne
et
principalement le
Royaume-Uni
en 1914
mise en place
du Commerce à
une guerre en 1929
en 1900
mets fini la your hands of Duty en fait
son nom naissance et Francesca Abigaëlle
au Louvre Thomas LV2 parents chrétien
d'origine Yoruba sont un groupe ethnique
principalement présent au Nigeria elle
reçoit deux une éducation stricte à la
fois Yoruba et chrétienne la petite
femelle et Pioneer des son plus jeune
âge puisqu'elle est la première fille
inscrite à l'école d'hab et eau potable
de 1914 à 1917 elle enseigne brièvement
au Nigeria puis elle part étudier en
Angleterre il fréquente une école pour
fille où elle apprend les locutions de
français la musique les tâches
domestiques c'est là-bas apparemment
face au racisme qu'elle subit qu'elle
décide d'abandonner son nom anglais et
de se faire appeler fournil à yeux qui
signifie donne-moi du bonheur en Europa
elle rentre au Nigeria en 1922 où elle
reprend l'enseignement et pose d'un
révérend anglican dans les années 30 le
couple investi dans une voiture qu'il
doit faire venir d'Angleterre est fait
une médaille aux devient la première
femme à passer le permis au Nigeria
pionnière encore et toujours et son
époux en 4 enfants une fille et trois
fils
je cesse d'enseigner après son mariage
mais sans engagement féministe se
dévoile des 1932 L près le club des
femmes d'aller au plus tard d'abord
destiné à l'apprentissage de travaux
manuels dans les années 40 cependant le
club pour un tour un peu plus politique
et s'ouvre femme de toutes les origines
sociales et sa tâche de plus en plus à
l'heure alphabétisation fous de Mélanie
on considère que la vraie situation des
femmes nigériane doit être jugé à partir
des femmes qui portent leur bébé sur
leur dos du matin au soir pour
travailler dans les champs et non à
partir des femmes qui utilise du thé du
sucre et de la farine au petit déjeuner
en 1944 elle mène une campagne réussi
pour empêcher les autorités locales de
confisquer illégalement du riz aux
femmes qui en vente sur les marchés
parce que ça se faisait avant ça en 1946
le club devient l'Union des femmes dans
une association féministe et
anticoloniale dans laquelle les femmes
parlent le Yoruba et s'attache apporter
des tenues traditionnelles en 1947
toujours Abeokuta elle mène une nouvelle
campagne contre une taxe spéciale
imposée aux femmes qui pratique le
commerce elle cet appel contre cette
taxe aux autorités britanniques circuler
des pétitions mais les autorités d'aller
au plus tard interdisent alors les
manifestations de femme pour tenter de
calmer les choses de médailles aux
réponds en organisant des pique-nique
qui attire jusque 10000 participantes
mais son durement réprimé par la police
les fonds de l'association permettre de
payer les frais de justice des femmes
interpellé en 1949 à force de
manifestation elle parvient à faire
temporairement indiquer le dirigeant de
la BO cottage et à faire suspendre cette
taxe à cette époque union des femmes ne
compte plus de 20000 membres les
première victoire de fumer la yole
incident à se montrer active au niveau
national et a lutté pour l'indépendance
de son pays LCL à plusieurs reprises au
conseil local d'habits hôpital opti un
siège à la maison des chefs en 1951 en
1947 encore elle se rend à Londres dans
le cadre d'une délégation dentelle et la
seule femme pour protester contre une
proposition de constitution des livres
un discours sur des problèmes que
rencontrent les femmes nigériane et
signer un article dans le débit worker
où elle accuse le colonialisme et
d'avoir marginaliser ces femmes
en 1949 corps de nouvelles discussion
lieux autour d'un projet de Constitution
elle est envoyé pour représenter la
ville de la BO quota est de nouveau la
seule femme à prendre part aux
discussions la même année elles font de
l'Union des femmes nigériane pour
défendre les droits des femmes dans tout
le pays est l'encre et des branches
local dans de nombreuses villes et tient
une conférence en 1953 pour le suffrage
des femmes elle perd son mari d'un
cancer de la prostate en 1955 ce qu'il a
marqué durant plus qu'elle était
toujours partagé entre ses engagements
politiques et le temps souvent trop bref
qu'elle passait avec lui durant sa
maladie durant les années qui suivent
elle ouvre de nouvelles écoles à aller
au coup tu as créé des lien avec
d'autres organisations féministe sur le
continent africain mais aussi en
Angleterre en Chine en URSS en Suisse en
Autriche en Tchécoslovaquie en Pologne
elle voyage beaucoup et les autorités
britanniques Rennes et qu'elle ne
diffuse l'idéologie communiste suite à
son voyage en Chine mais plutôt comme
une Africaine socialiste à cause de ça
craint pourtant elle ne peut plus
renouveler son passeport et les
États-Unis lui refuse un visa quand elle
en fait la demande une conférence de
presse pour affirmer qu'elle est pas
communiste mais sans succès elle de
récupérer son passeport qu'en 1960 à
l'indépendance du Nigeria l'indépendance
du pays permet enfin aux femmes
d'accéder au droit de vote inscrire dans
la Constitution l' œuvre de fou de
médailles aux touche à sa fin elle
continue de s'investir pour les droits
des femmes dans le cadre de plusieurs
associations elle est admise à l'ordre
du Niger en 1965 et obtient le Prix
Lénine pour la paix en 1970 vers la fin
de sa vie son fils Fela Kuti chanteur
célèbre est activiste prend la parole à
son tour en critiquant la dictature de
loup segun Obasanjo il fait de sa maison
une commune dans laquelle les opposants
politiques peuvent se rassembler et
qu'il surnomme la République de Kalakuta
de reconnaissant pas l'autorité en place
il se fait arrêter à de nombreuses
reprises et critique l'armée et le
gouvernement nigérien dans son album
zombie en 1976
en représailles le 18 février 1977 des
militaires prennent d'assaut la maison
familiale de Lagos se saisissent de
famille Hayot qui rendait visite à son
fils ce jour-là et la jette par la
fenêtre elle tombe dans le coma et 17 de
ses blessures un an plus tard le 13
avril 1978 à l'âge de 77 ans le
gouvernement déclare que la maison des
Ransome Kuti a été assailli par mille
soldats non identifié l'hommage rendu à
fumer et il ment il est racontée par sa
petite fille d'Émile Aussonne petit lors
de la levée de son corps il y avait des
centaines de personnes à la morgue moi
je pensais que c'était à cause de mon
père mais quand nous sommes arrivés à
Abeokuta des vendeuses du marché était
tout debout elle patiente et devant les
portes Abeokuta elle sur des milliers
des milliers à marcher et accompagner le
cercueil de ma grand-mère jusqu'à
l'école où s'est tenue la veillée
funéraire elle est enterré dans le
caveau de son mari un an plus tard son
fils dépose un cercueil devant les
quartiers généraux du Nigeria pour
commémorer ça mord ses frères et soeur
continue également de jouer un rôle
important dans le développement pénis
dans le domaine de l'éducation de la
santé des armées de la politique le nom
de la demeure très connu au Nigeria où
elle est devenue une figure nationale
elle reste une influence pour beaucoup
de politicienne et de féministe actuelle
sa petite-fille Guidel je crois qu'elle
était féministe mais pas dans le sens le
plus moderne vous savez qu'elle était
juste une femme est chez les Yoruba les
femmes sont des personnalités très fort
ma grand-mère était un personnage fort
elle était discipline et courageuse
forte d'esprit et avec une volonté de
fer elle était prête à mourir pour ses
idées le gouvernement nigérien propose
de la faire figurer sur un billet en
2012 mais son petit-fils trouve la
démarche déplacer au vu de l'implication
des autorités de l'époque dans sa mort
il refuse
j'espère que cette vidéo vous a plu j'ai
choisi pourrai pas te parler d'une femme
un peu moins connu en tout cas en Europe
parce que parce que là ça aussi que ça
sert les gens de la madame pas de parler
des femmes que vous me réclamez donc
vous connaissez déjà mais des femmes que
vous ne connaissez pas et qui mérite
d'être connu j'ai beaucoup dit connu
dans cette phrase
pour vous situer j'étais censé sortir un
chronique de prof en début novembre mais
les recherches m'ont pris énormément de
temps et maintenant je me retrouve avec
90 pages qui constituent mes recherches
condensé et donc le faire un épisode de
2030 minutes donc c'est très long et
j'ai un petit peu une panne d'écriture
sur 7 épisode d'où l'idée de sortir
agenda badass en attendant ce genre de
la boîte à ce que vous venez de voir
mais je continue d'avancer puisque à
côté je travaille aussi sur mon prochain
livre livre d'histoire donc j'ai aussi
commencé à écrire un roman donc j'écris
beaucoup et du coup la l'épisode
chronique de prof a été un peu mis de
côté c'est temps-ci d'autant que comme
je viens de te le dire il est compliqué
à écrire mais j'y reviendrai bien c'est
pas terminé je suis pas sûr qu'ils
sortent en 2021 pour tout vous dire ça
sera peut-être plus tôt en 2022 début
2022 pour maintenant parce que c'est
clair mais vous le verrez quand vous le
verrez par me comprendre et en attendant
ben peut-être y aura un autre genre
entre deux peut-être que je sortirai une
vidéo sur les films que j'ai vu au
cinéma cette année parce que il y en
avait pas eu le temps que ça mais cette
année on a pu retourner un petit peu
donc ça dure voilà donc je sais plus où
j'en étais donc on se retrouve pour les
prochaines vidéos et oui je voulais vous
dire aussi que c'est bientôt Noël si
vous manquez d'idées de cadeaux j'ai
toujours en stock et dans toutes les
librairies officiel
je me trompe toujours de livre jamais le
bon livre
vous êtes très attention
improvisation oui je voulais vous dire
aussi que puisque noël approche si vous
manquez d'idées pour vos proches vous
pouvez rire et cette fois ça veut dire
quoi que l'autre était très bon aussi en
espérant qu'il ait écrit ça c'est la vie
quotidienne au Moyen-Âge qui est sorti
en décembre 2020 maintenant que j'ai
écrit et qui parle comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer de la vie quotidienne au
Moyen-Âge que ça soit d'hygiène
l'alimentation les loisirs l'éducation
plein de choses bien et donc voilà au
frais le si vous souhaitez
et à bientôt
[Musique]